各位今天這集真的會害你的電腦工具列直接爆炸
每一個都能讓你的工作效率直接上天堂那種等級
這集看完你會懷疑自己之前到底是怎麽走過來的
嗨各位又是我AJ 歡迎來到一個全新的系列
電腦上的神隊友推薦 之後我們會固定整理5個超好用的電腦軟體工具
不管你是學生
上班族 剪輯師 還是整天跟3C打交道的夥伴
這集應該都能夠找到一個能夠救你的人生工具
趁現在開始之前呢哎幫我訂閱按讚才不會錯過每一集的懶人包
話不多說我們就直接開始啦
第一個登場的選手叫做 DeskIn
如果你還不認識他
你可能會認為他只是另外一個遠端桌面的軟體
但事情沒有那麽簡單
我們實測了之後發現呢
這家夥根本就是為了我們這些想當薪水小偷
啊不是 想當極致運用時間的人而設計的
DeskIn三個我很喜歡的功能
保證你看完會想把電腦裡面就有那套軟體給刪了
第一招叫做硬體效能這鍋 讓公司電腦來背
大家都有這種經驗吧
出門在外突然要改個文件或者是改個幾百MB的PPT
用手機或是平板來弄
別傻了只會讓你手機燙到可以直接煎荷包蛋
這時候你就可以用DeskIn 用手機連回你公司那台效能怪獸
所有的運算讓電腦跑
你只要負責收割成果就好 看這邊 電腦做好了簡報
直接用它檔案傳輸的功能一鍵 咻一下拉回手機
不管你是忘了帶報告還是要傳大檔案
完全不用經過雲端硬碟
在那邊上傳下載等到天荒地老
這才叫真正的雲端辦公
再來這招
專治螢幕缺乏焦慮症
很多人用筆電工作最痛苦的就是視窗畫面太小
每個程式都要不停的放大縮小
搞得心情很煩
DeskIn有個很猛的功能叫做虛擬螢幕擴充
就算你物理上只有一台螢幕
只要你帶著手機或者是帶一台iPad
他就可以用軟體幫你遠端生出其他的延伸螢幕
你看這個三刀流的操作
左邊開Gemini 幫你想文案
中間幫你做簡報
右邊掛著這個股市看盤或者是偷看我們的影片
實踐螢幕財富自由
就是這麽簡單
第三個情境我覺得比工作更重要
叫做工具人的自我救贖
你一定遇過這種狀況 人在外面爽
家里長輩突然間打電話來說 這個電腦視窗都不見了
哎呀那個我好像點了中獎連結
以前你可能要隔空通靈教學半小時
現在你可以直接DeskIn連回家里的電腦或者是另外一台智慧型手機
因為它有針對遠端優化
延遲感非常的低
你可以直接幫你的爸媽把那個不知名的防毒軟體給他關掉
或者是把消失的接龍把他叫出來
不用回家就能當孝子
這功能無價
最後成為新時代工具人
沒有AI怎麽行呢
DeskIn最近也加上了AI助理的功能
如果你連線覺得卡頓或者是突然找不到某個設定在哪里
不用去Google爬文
你直接問他
他會給你最即時的調整
建議甚至還幫你排除故障
就在旁邊做了一個隨叫隨到的IT人員
只差不會幫你倒咖啡而已
最後我必須老實說為什麽要推他
因為最大的原因有一個 就是他對免費用戶非常的佛心
不同於其他X牌的軟體動不動就說你是不是商業使用
然後把你你踢下去 DeskIn免費版直接開放個人商業使用
不管你是要救急工作還是遠端當孝子
這款軟體絕對是你目前必裝的神器 連結我已經幫大家準備在下面了
歡迎各位精打細算的免費仔
不用猶豫了
載下來真的有時候會救你一命
第二個要跟各位分享的是一套叫做Handy的開源免費的語音轉文字的程式
準確找尋我會建議各位加一個叫做GitHub這個關鍵字
你就會看到這個
那這個軟體你就可以直接在旁邊這邊release
然後把它下載下來
為什麽推薦他因為他資源幾乎所有的平台包含Mac
Windows arm版的Windows你就可以去選擇你適合的這個軟體
那如果你在這地方懶得找呢
你也可以去Handy他們的官網
他們的官網叫做Handy.computer
然後你就可以去download Handy for Mac或者是other platform
他就會告訴你說 這是基本上我能夠想到的這個安裝包他都已經做好了
我就簡單開一個Google文件
然後你就直接好打開Handy這個程式
那介面大概長這個樣子 他會要求你去下載這個模型
那我目前用了我覺得比較喜歡的是whisper media這個模型
那當然就看你的電腦的能耐
這一套軟體就是它可以在完全斷網的情況之下
用你的電腦直接跑語音轉文字
就是以前那些東西都要跑到雲端去
那這個東西就他直接跑到你的電腦里面
當你今天有一些比如說機密會議啦 或者是有些資料
你不想要透過AI去幫你去做這個辨識
那再來他一個很有趣的地方就是他是透過快捷鍵
快捷鍵去做這個Transcript
比如說我現在Mac里面的快捷鍵 像是設定是option加space
那比如說我今天就準備好了一份這個稿件
你就打開Handy這個程式然後你就用option+space
下面就會出現一個聽打的符號
Chat GPT 5.2是open AI最新推出的人工智慧模型
放掉下面會有一個小小的 transcribing
好他就會開始幫你做這個語音的識別
你可以去在language這邊自動的去把它改成這個繁體中文
去強迫他一定要生成這個繁體中文的內容
那這樣應該準確率就會再高一點了
另外還在這個界面里面還有一個叫做history的東西
他會幫你去記錄辨識出來的結果還有你當初錄音的那個檔案
他都會存在你的電腦里面給你做參考
Google在11月底的時候正式宣布推出了一套AI程式開發的工具叫做Anti Gravity
我們最近啊大家應該都有在用NotebookLM
好那NotebookLM有一個新的功能叫做簡報生成 還有資訊圖表
那如果我想要把這些簡報大量的往我的GOOGLE簡報里面放
但是因為他下載之後的格式是PDF
那我希望去把它放到PPT或者放到GoogleSlide里面去的時候
那個PDF的格式是沒有辦法很快速的去做匯入的
所以我的歪腦筋就馬上想說
那有沒有可能叫Anti Gravity幫我批次轉檔
我就開一個專案資料夾
然後把我的PDF放進去
然後我就可以跟AI講說
這個請幫我把Calude的那份PDF檔案轉換成1920*1080的圖片
他會去抓取你給他的這個工作資料夾里面的檔案
他就幫你生成程式碼 那比如說他就幫我寫一個像這個PDF to PNG
那里面寫什麽呢
說實話你想知道你可以去研究
但是我是懶得看的所以就不重要
反正就讓他跑那跑完之後他就自動幫我把程式碼然後生成然後去做執行
就我最近的這個測試
如果你的電腦沒有安裝PYTHON這個套件的話
你需要手動的去裝PYTHON
如果你用的是Mac
那Mac本身是內鍵安裝的這個功能
所以他就會問你說要不要裝
你再按安裝同意 然後就裝好然後就可以開始用
然後就會自動報轉檔 就問你說 你看還幫你說我要做PYTHON3 執行PDF to PNG
這個
然後把這個奧捷的這個檔案變成一個資料夾
所以你只要案Accept然後你看13頁好1234567他就開始轉檔
非常的爽快
出來之後就變成像這樣子就一張圖一張圖
而且這張圖都是full HD
因為我要求他去下1920*1080這個尺寸
接下來Affinity那你可能還是沒有聽過他
但是他現在的母公司你一定有聽過他的母公司叫做Canva
在今年10月的時候
Canva正式宣布完全免費
所以他甚至有iPad APP也現在全部都免費了
那你只要去Affinity的官網然後去登入你的Canva的賬號
所以我最常用的事情是 就是使用它這個Victor的這個功能
然後我就可以去把一些比如說AI生成的一些SVG區的格式
向量格式的時候變得非常非常好用
因為你可以根據你的需求來去把里面的原件把它刪掉
那如果你是Canva的付費用戶
比如說你是教育版或者是專業版或者是非營利版
你就可以在這個里面去加上Canva的AI的這些相關的功能
最後一個我想跟各位分享一個
我覺得最近資料傳遞的時候還蠻好用的一個工具
叫做LocalSend
那他也是一個開源跨平台完全免費的
說白話就是apple系列的那個Airdrop 那如果你是拿安卓
就可以裝一下LocalSend
那它使用的這個條件就是你必須電腦上面要裝這個軟體
然後你的手機里面也要裝這個軟體
打開這個軟體之後 你只要讓你的電腦跟你的手機都停留
在同一個Wifi的環境之下
就可以去做到這樣子的一個點對點的這個檔案的傳輸
那比如說 我們就把這個軟體在這電腦上把它下載下來
然後你就可以比如說在發送的模式隨便丟一個
什麽PDF檔案過去給他 發送過去
然後這個對方就會說要傳送兩個檔案給你
就按接受 你就會看到這樣子迅速的檔案就完成了傳輸了
所以傳統如果你要做這樣資料傳遞你可能會拿隨身碟
但隨身碟可能會中毒
你又說我會用LINE 可是LINE的話你要先傳上去再抓下來 其實是不方便的
你通過LocalSend他等於是機器對機器直接點對點
而且速度速用你們家的Wifi分享器的速度 所以絕對會比LINE來得快上許多
好以上就是我們這一集介紹的各種我們最近找到的一些實用的啊小工具
那當然也歡迎你把你自己的這個私藏的小工具
在影片下方留言跟其他的網友做分享
那我們就在這個地方下次影片再見 拜拜